a horrifying day for the united states
as 12 u.s marines are dead that number
is likely to increase over the course of
the next 24 hours because many more are
wounded overall the terrorist attacks in
kabul today have resulted in at least 60
deaths and 140 wounded many of those
people are of course american soldiers
and service members joining us on the
line to discuss brigadier general blaine
holt retired u.s air force brigadier
general was a former c-17 combat
commander and us deputy military
representative to nato regular general
thanks so much for joining the show
appreciate it really rough day obviously
it is thanks for having me back ben so
let's talk about what's going on on the
ground uh have you been in touch with
anybody who's on the ground at the
airport at this point
i have been on the touch uh in touch
with several who have been working the
situation on the ground it's uh
it's absolutely chaos as you might
imagine so can you give us the latest on
on what is the sort of breakdown what is
the security situation like over there
um you know are they expecting more
terrorist attacks in the near future
here yeah i think they have to they've
been certainly told to be aware that
more are on the way um
so far from the sources i have on the
ground we've got three suicide bombers i
know that two are being reported but
there were three
um that i know of um
they hit a gate
and uh a hotel where americans were
being uh collected my understanding was
there was quite a population between
those two that are very tight tightly
packed in together
and uh the the carnage that's on the
ground including our fallen uh marines
and uh and navy uh uh colleague uh is is
it's it's just it's it's incredible uh
at the same time we have seen that some
of the aircraft have been taking small
arms fire out of the field as they have
either dispersed or taken off out of
kabul and the mission goes on we we have
heard of some extractions by special
operations forces but obviously not
anything robust and there's still
a very grave security situation there
kabul the commanders certainly have
their hands full what i can say
is is that our service men and women are
performing uh well beyond expectations
that anybody could have for them in this
kind of environment it is a fundamental
betrayal of men and women in the
american military to put them in
positions where they are likely to be in
this sort of situation we're speaking
with brigadier general retired blaine
holt um so general uh when when we talk
about the situation on the ground a
couple airport maybe you can draw a
picture a little bit for us of what the
geography of kabul airport is like so
when we hear that i think most americans
think of lax or they think of kennedy
they think of these vast panoramic
airports with tons of runways
and various entry points
what what is kabul airport actually like
so kabul is very small and uh it's all
packed in with a lot of wide-body
aircraft there is
a ring road that goes around the field
it's got about seven gates um
but it's it's very very difficult to
defend because it's porous um our you
know we've got a lot of people on the
ground there to do airfield defense but
um you could you can easily see where
those seven entry points uh you could
pack in
a crowd telling who's who and and
sorting out a terrorist from someone
who's not a terrorist is very difficult
to exercise they did have warnings
overnight that there was going to be
something imminent coming to the field
they took those seriously
and we were all questioning wow we're
not asking people to come to the airport
well this is this is the reason why that
was well one of the things that we
learned today from the head of centcom
general kenneth mckenzie is that we have
been using the taliban to provide
essentially security and screening at
the airport that we were using them to
actually
push
sort of uh pat people down make sure
they were the new tsa was the taliban
and so we have obviously an excellent
history with the taliban in in having
them fight terrorism the last time we
asked them to fight terrorism they took
down the world trade center attacked the
pentagon uh and uh and brought down a
plane in in pennsylvania or at least
provided cover to al-qaeda to do so and
then refused to turn al-qaeda over so
they have a great job they've done a
great job historically of preventing
terrorism we are now heavily reliant on
the taliban uh the the head of centcom
said today that he is honestly not sure
as to whether the taliban did this by
accident or whether they just let the
isis suicide bombers right on through
and yet we continue to rely on the
taliban to quote-unquote provide
security
yeah no that this is going to get looked
at
for years after this is over but one of
the things that uh we have seen in the
past four days and this is not by any
stretch of the imagination
concurrence with how this is gone
it is that
the taliban have insisted that they are
able to block points checkpoints and the
situation with this evacuation that we
found ourselves in they have actually
provided some security at the gates in
their own best interest not in the
united states best interest that's a key
difference here because
for the taliban to take the country back
they don't want to see things like this
happen on our exit because then
then it doesn't go in the in the method
that they wanted the isis is their enemy
as well and it makes us wonder whether
they've got control of anything would
taliban let somebody through
uh who knows but what i can say is is
you're absolutely right to question
um whether it's wise to have any kind of
relationship with them or put ourselves
into a position to have a relationship
with them on something as
as key as this with so many people still
left to be saved so speaking of that
obviously this entire effort was
designed in order to extract americans
from kabul uh at this point we are
hearing that there are over a thousand
american citizens who are left in kabul
the number of citizens plus green card
holders is way larger than that and the
number of afghan citizens we've
basically left for dead there is
hundreds of thousands i mean there's
just no question that tens of thousands
of people are going to be slaughtered at
the hands of the taliban at this point
and not only that we're now learning
from politico that our wise leaders
decided that an excellent idea would be
to actually hand a list of the people
who wanted to evacuate over to the
taliban so they could facilitate the
security we handed them a list of all
the people the afghans were applying for
special immigrant visas the american
citizens the green card holders so the
taliban now have a complete list of all
the people we were attempting to
evacuate
it boggles the mind
yeah and we we
from the ground we heard reports of the
taliban coming on to kabul and basically
redlining people off of flights that we
have siv status that that had a clear
ticket out i'm working in particular uh
with a family to try to facilitate this
family that was 600 feet from their
freedom
uh to with papers to get on an airplane
to go to a european country and the
taliban intervened and now they're
they're they're fleeing for their lives
trying to get to a land-based border and
these are you know three kids and a mom
and a dad and their their big crime is
uh supporting a christian charity in the
country that was doing humanitarian work
this is this is absolutely horrible and
then we talk about
just kabul the one thing that i want to
expand the conversation out is there's
33 provinces and there's people all over
the country and we're getting reports on
the ground of horrific events that the
taliban which is trying to repackage
itself into this oh we've we've changed
no no no that's not what's happening in
the 33 provinces they are
uh raping and killing women they're
hanging police officers who were trying
to keep order they are running around
with loudspeakers uh calling for people
that they're looking for
and what's going to happen after we are
gone and the lights go out in
afghanistan and they can't see internet
we can't see them
what will happen then and uh and so this
you know i i've said this this is as bad
as we could see 20 years of war ending
up we're speaking brigadier general
retired blaine holt uh so general uh
we've heard from members of the pentagon
that we are in fact going to pursue the
people who pursued the terrorist attack
today what capacity do we actually have
to do that considering that we basically
have no eyes and ears anywhere outside
of kabul international airport at this
point and our military is essentially
restricted to kabul international
airport so what capacity do we actually
have to to perform those sorts of
operations right now
yep so so there's methodologies that i
can't talk about but i will tell you
that it may not be today and it may not
be tomorrow but but we have the ability
to hold any target on the globe at risk
24 7 365. we we if we have the will
uh we will not let this pass and i would
urge military uh leaders and civilian
leaders uh to strongly pursue the course
of action if that that if that's what
they say they are going to do then they
should do that
brigadier general retired blayne hall
really appreciate your time on this
terrible day and of course please convey
our our best and uh and all of our
support to the people who are on the
ground that you're talking to right now
absolutely will and i will tell you that
in our country there are 17 million
veterans been we are all watching this
many of us served in afghanistan we are
absolutely jaws open and despondent and
we wish that we were with our crews and
our ground forces now i can tell you on
october 7th on the 20th anniversary of
oef
we're calling for as many vets as
possible to meet us all at the lincoln
memorial to reaffirm uh our oath to the
constitution that has no expiration and
to basically reconnect with our nation
and to pray for our fallen and our
wounded well that is again brigadier
general retired blaine holt appreciate
the time sir
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button so you stay up
to date with all our future content